Transcriptor: Yonara Anastacio
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Hola, soy Verónica Toussaint
y soy adicta a hacer reír.
Cuando era pequeña, se metían mucho
conmigo por tener la boca tan grande.
Que si tenía boca de buzón,
boca de guasón, de chupón
o que si era yo la viuda.
Hasta en el dentista,
que cuando vas te dice: “abre la boca”,
a mí me dice: “No tanto”.
En serio.
Y como buena niña yo lloraba, porque me
molestaban por tener la boca tan grande.
Hasta que un profe me dijo:
“No les hagas caso.
Un día tu boca va a ser tu distintivo”.
La verdad es que lo escuché,
pero obviamente no lo entendí,
empezando porque en ese momento
no sabía lo que era “un distintivo”.
Y confieso que durante muchísimo tiempo
me dio vergüenza tener la boca grande.
Cuando le robaba a mi madre
su barra de labios rojo intenso,
para pintar mi bocota
y no una boquita pequeña, como la suya.
Era porque yo también quería ser grande
y hermosa como mi madre.
Cuando descubría mi travesura,
me pedía que me la despintara,
porque parecía un payaso.
Sé que ella lo hacía desde el amor,
pero hasta hace poco no entendí
que esa frase sin importancia
me había marcado
y que seguía persiguiéndome.
Si me pintaba la boca de rojo,
siempre estaba consciente
de no sonreír al 100 %,
porque sabía que se me ponía
boca de guasón.
Y adivinen.
Si hoy subo una foto con la boca roja
a cualquier red social,
lo primero que me escriben es:
tienes boca de guasón.
No, hombre, pues ¡qué creativos!
Nunca lo había oído.
Lo cierto es que he luchado mucho
para no permitir que esos comentarios
lleguen hasta mi niña interior,
a la que regañaron
por haberse pintado la boca de rojo.
Y he aprendido a reírme de mí misma,
entendiendo que la risa cura.
¿Se han puesto a pensar
que nadie nos enseña a sonreír?
Es curioso el tema de la sonrisa,
porque no hay manera de salir ilesos
si alguien nos sonríe de manera honesta.
Por ejemplo, un bebé sonríe por instinto
cuando ni siquiera es capaz
de sostener su propia cabecita.
No hay bienvenida más cálida
que una sonrisa. Piénsenlo
Si van caminando por la calle
y les sonríen,
devuelven la sonrisa inmediatamente.
O cuando vemos que alguien está sonriendo,
sabemos que esa persona
está bien o va a estarlo.
Afortunadamente llevo más o menos un año
sonriendo a mis anchas,
sonriendo sin importarme
el tamaño de mi boca,
o si a alguien le parece
grotesca mi sonrisa.
Un año entregándome a la sensación
de sonreír más y con todo mi ser.
Porque he entendido que la risa
es una moneda de cambio universal,
sin caducidad, y sobre todo,
es la llave que abre de manera automática
cualquier puerta, y que tiene el poder
de suavizar hasta el corazón más duro.
Allá por el año 2000 acabé
la carrera de comunicación
y empecé mi formación como actriz.
Y en mi primer día, el maestro me dice
que pase al frente y me presente.
Entonces digo: “Soy Verónica Tussaint,
y me gustaría ser actriz”.
Y me dice: “¿Te gustaría o eres?”.
Dije: “Me gustaría”.
“Pues empieza por asumirte actriz, y luego
ya puedes empezar a estudiar”, me dijo.
Me quedé en shock, y luego vino
una pregunta aún más fuerte:
“¿Te gusta llamar la atención, Verónica?”
“O sea, sí , sí me gusta, pero lo que
pasa es que no siempre...”.
Empecé a justificarme
y me interrumpió y dijo:
“No, está bien llamar
la atención, no pasa nada.
Sino no podrías estar
en un escenario, está bien”.
“¿Cómo?
¿Cómo que está bien?
Pero es que en nuestra sociedad
querer llamar la atención
es un rasgo de narcisismo que no está bien
y que tienes que moderar a toda costa.
Eso no puede estar bien”.
Y me dice: “Pues sí, olvida lo aprendido
y empieza a abrazar lo que eres
y lo que te gusta hacer”.
“¿En serio, está bien llamar la atención?”
“Es que no solo está bien, lo necesitas”.
Y ese fue el momento
en que dejé de luchar conmigo misma
y empecé a romper
con todas las estructuras aprendidas
del deber ser frente a quien soy.
Me reconcilié, y pude entender
que estaba justificando algo
que es totalmente instintivo y natural.
Y poco a poco fui habitando
este nuevo estado,
y con los años aprendí
a dosificar a mi favor.
Caminar tras bambalinas,
entre los camiones de equipo,
cables de luz, cámaras, micrófonos,
hace y hacía que se me encogiera
el estómago, me emocionaba.
Y estaba dispuesta
a no cobrar ni un solo euro
con tal de estar
entre todos esos elementos.
Sin duda había encontrado
un lugar para ser feliz.
Parece, pero no todo es color de rosa,
porque nadie te dice,
sobre todo si tienes un problema
con la tolerancia a la frustración,
que esta carrera es una maestría.
¡Qué digo una maestría!, es un doctorado
para trabajar tus demonios.
Que si eres alta, que si eres baja,
que si eres vieja, morena, blanca,
y no se lo van a creer:
que si eres bocona.
Y ahí estaba yo, joven, llena de ilusiones
y dispuesta a soportar el rechazo,
pero a seguir haciendo lo que me
apasiona, lo que me hace feliz.
Lo cual me parece toda una suerte.
Vivir de lo que nos apasiona
es de los regalos más grandes de la vida.
Eso y el pan dulce,
que no tiene nada que ver,
pero me parece importante mencionarlo.
Un día me encontré con un compañero
de la universidad y me dijo:
“Necesito contarte esta historia.
Hace un par de años intenté suicidarme
y mientras me recuperaba en el hospital,
de repente apareciste en la televisión,
y tu sonrisa me hizo recapacitar
y pensé: “Si ella puede, yo puedo”.
A lo que voy, es que me cambió la vida
saber que un gesto tan simple
como una sonrisa actuada
ayudó a alguien a tomar fuerzas.
¿No se supone que el entretenimiento
solo es para distraer?
Tal vez sí, pero además de distraer,
comunica, conecta y ayuda a reflexionar.
Y cuando juntas tu pasión
con algo mucho más grande que tú,
y en este caso, tienes el poder
de hacerlo masivamente,
suceden cosas inimaginables, mágicas.
Y si hablamos de imaginación, permítanme
hablarles del método de improvisación,
algo que siempre voy a considerar
como una oportunidad de oro en mi vida.
Quería hacerlo de verdad.
Así que estudié, me preparé
y fui a hacer el casting,
para pertenecer
a ese círculo súper cerrado.
Y me rechazaron, y me desearon
más suerte para el próximo año.
Pero no hubo próximo año
Pero tras varios años hice el piloto
de un programa de televisión.
Duramos seis temporadas y me llevé a los
actores más destacados que tiene el país.
Es el mejor trabajo del mundo.
Estaba aprendiendo de mis compañeros,
estaba en la televisión.
Además me pagaban por ir a jugar
y a reírme todo el día.
Es más, voy a salir del armario aquí
y les voy va a decir
que lo hubiera hecho gratis.
Yo ya era parte de un programa
de humor blanco para toda la familia.
Y no saben lo que era para mí que me
dijeran en la calle que veían el programa
con la abuelita, los padres y los hermanos
y que se olvidaban de la rutina
y de los problemas.
Eso dio pie a mi mayor vicio
en esta vida: hacer reir.
Y a lo del pan dulce también,
por supuesto.
Años después, los caminos misteriosos
de la actuación me llevaron
a formar parte de un show
de cabaret político,
en el que me enfrenté
al reto de escribir un show
que, por su naturaleza,
requiere modificarse cada semana,
de acuerdo a los debates de los candidatos
y, por supuesto, a las hermosas
metidas de pata que hacen en sus campañas.
Mira que hacerles la competencia
a nuestros candidatos no es fácil,
porque ellos, sin lugar a dudas,
son comediantes de primer nivel,
involuntarios, así como los bebés
que no pueden sostener sus cabecitas,
pero comediantes al fin.
Cuando no me tocaba actuar, esperaba
entretelones, y no saben cómo disfrutaba
esperar que el chiste que yo había escrito
llegara hasta las butacas
y ver qué pasaba con el público.
Y de pronto, llegaban las risas,
los aplausos, y mientras, yo, en silencio,
sonreía al ver como más de 600 personas
se reían gracias una ocurrencia mía.
Cuando salían del espectáculo decían:
“Ahora ya no sé ni por quién votar”.
Crear conciencia social y política
por medio de la comedia.
Pum.
Me encantaría decirles
que yo inventé ese método.
Pero no es nuevo.
De hecho es el oficio del bufón.
El bufón se vestía de manera colorida,
usaba campanas, pico, sombrero,
cara maquillada
para resaltar sus facciones,
y se pintaba la boca,
para llamar la atención.
El bufón es ese personaje que incluso
podía decir que Dios no existía
y no lo mandaban a la hoguera.
Era quien podía hablar
descaradamente del abuso de poder
o incluso burlarse del rey en su cara.
Pero el objetivo del bufón no era burlarse
de la sociedad, al contrario,
era ayudarla.
En la comedia se puede hablar
de todas las atrocidades,
y gracias al ruido que genera la risa,
despertar al inconsciente más adormilado.
La comedia ya había llegado a mi vida.
Era parte de ella, y para mi suerte,
llegó para quedarse.
Yo era comediante y ni siquiera
me había dado cuenta.
Y lo sabía porque siempre
que contaba una anécdota,
iba aderezada de unos ataques de risa.
Los hacía reír.
Y era súper chistoso.
En fin.
Ser mujer no es fácil
ni en esta época ni en ninguna.
Pero agrégenle una mujer comediante
en este siglo y en este país.
¿Cómo les explico el reto
y el acto de valentía que es eso?.
Imagínense que los orígenes de la comedia,
están más o menos en el 1200 a. C
en donde nacen diferentes tipos
de comedia de todos los colores y sabores.
Vamos a la comedia antigua,
esa que hacía Aristófanes,
que todos conocemos,
la de enredos o situaciones,
que era parte de los malentendidos,
o la comedia física
que nace de los accidentes.
Esa a mí me choca, porque me da
una angustia horrorosa.
Pero también está la comedia musical,
donde todos los personajes
cantan, bailan y son felices.
Y la comedia satírica,
que destaca los defectos
y se burla de las instituciones
y de los individuos.
Y ¿adivinen qué?
En todo este lío y toda esta teoría
que acabo de contarles,
las mujeres sólo tenían un rol figurativo,
y la mayoría de las veces
eran interpretadas por hombres.
Yo tuve la suerte de empezar a escribir
para programas de televisión
y me encontré que en las mesas de guión,
la mayoría de esos escritores
eran hombres, y para colmo,
seguían escribiendo comedia
como en los programas de los 70,
en donde las mujeres siempre cumplían
el rol del personaje marginal
o de la mujer voluptuosa sin cerebro.
En ese entonces, esa parte de la comedia
no había evolucionado mucho.
Y confieso, que en varias ocasiones
caí en la trampa
y escribí esos chistes machistas
y poco amables.
Y no solo eso, también fui parte
durante muchos años, de esa comedia
que ataca y se burla de las personas
desde el poder de los medios.
Sí , eso da risa.
Sin lugar a dudas funciona,
pero también lastima.
Había algo en mí
que no acababa de ser congruente.
Me parecía demasiado caro
el precio que se pagaba por esas risas
fáciles e inmediatas.
Y empecé a cuestionarme si ese era
el tipo de comedia que me gustaba hacer.
Y la respuesta es que no.
No tanto.
Porque esa comedia
proviene de la intimidación.
Y miren que soy buena intimidando.
Pero empecé a no sentirme bien,
al punto de no poder dormir por la noche.
La comedia puede ser benigna
pero picante, irónica pero inteligente.
Puede evolucionar junto con la sociedad
sin dejar de ser valiente, incisiva
o sin herir susceptibilidades.
Desde que entendí eso,
comprendí que mi gran reto
es lograr el equilibrio.
Y ahora voy poco a poco, agarrándole
la onda a mi propia comedia,
a lo que me da risa con mis 45 años,
desde la óptica femenina,
como actriz y como comunicadora.
Y he comprobado que cuando me río
desde lo más profundo de mi ser,
desde las entrañas, y me permito perder
toda la compostura e incluso llorar,
y me doblo para todos lados.
Ahí es cuando hay resonancia,
es cuando hay conexión.
La risa crea lazos e incluso aumenta
la intimidad creando complicidad.
Don Nilsen que es un lingüista muy famoso,
dice que las carcajadas difícilmente
suceden cuando estamos solos.
Y tiene mucho sentido.
Piensen en ese momento mágico en el que
se giran a ver a alguien y se ríen
y ya saben perfectamente qué está pasando
y no necesitas ni una sola palabra.
Incluso pensamos que eso es telepatía,
pero en realidad
es el poder social de la risa.
Si alguien se carcajea de manera honesta
y verdadera, juro que es casi imposible
no dejarse llevar también,
y sumarse a esa oleada de sonrisas
y de ruidos estridentes, de los que
ni siquiera importa qué los generó.
Olvídense de la Covid.
La risa es de las cosas más contagiosas
que hay en el mundo.
Y afortunadamente da vida, mucha vida.
Por eso tener la oportunidad
de hacer reír a los enfermos
es de las cosas más luminosas que hay.
Enfocarte en la alegría
y no quedarte en la tragedia.
Nunca voy a olvidar
el día que hice una visita a un hospital
y había un niñito que tenía la mano
atada a una tablita
para que no se le saliera el suero.
Y el niño jugaba a que era un avioncito,
pero se moría de la risa
porque se le atascaba la manita
en el cable del suero.
También había otra niñita, que no sé qué
le había pasado, pero no podía ver,
y le gustaba cantar reguetón
y cuando acababa la canción
le gustaba el gran final que era:
“Me tapo un ojo, me tapo
el otro y nada que ver”.
¿Ven?, los niños lo tienen clarísimo.
La risa pone en proporción las cosas,
y si se entregan por completo a la risa,
a esa risa que pasa como un cometa,
pueden lograr olvidarse de todo,
hasta del dolor o del sufrimiento.
Todos somos adictos a la risa.
Yo no conozco a nadie que no ame reír.
Agarrarte la barriga, tomar aire
y decir: “Ya no puedo más”,
hasta que duelan
las mejillas y la mandíbula.
Ese suspiro que logra
que una pequeña pausa suceda
y alguien se vuelva a acordar
de la risa y reviente una vez más
con una oleada todavía más fuerte.
Y nunca falta la persona que dice: “Ya,
por favor, por favor, me voy a morir,
ya, ya, por favor”.
Por fin se agotan las risas
y llega un momento de total relajación,
donde ya todo el mundo
está relajado y moviendo la cabeza.
Y uno no puede creer que lleve horas
riéndose de esa misma estupidez.
Y ahí es donde llega esa sensación
de plenitud que es casi meditativa.
Y es que la risa es un ancla al bienestar.
Se liberan todo tipo de endorfinas,
que obviamente hacen
que nos sintamos mejor físicamente.
Pueden estar devastados, enfadados
o enfermos, pero si se dan la oportunidad,
hay un momento en el que vuelven
a conectar con la risa
y eso les recuerda que van a estar bien,
que eso también va a pasar.
Por eso la risa sana.
La risa nos trae al presente.
Es un aquí y ahora.
Es tan humana.
Es primitiva, básica.
Es vida.
Rían desde lo más antiguo de su ser.
Rían con su niño interior.
Ríanse de su vida, de todas sus vidas,
ríanse y no dejen pasar ni un solo día
sin la oportunidad de reír,
ni de sonreír por cualquier cosa.
Hacer reír también es un acto de amor.
Necesitamos reír más.
Rían mucho,
hasta que les duela la barriga.
Sean sencillos y contagien a todo el mundo
con unas buenas carcajadas.
Hagan todo lo que tengan que hacer
para ser felices.
Y mientras lo hacen, rían.